around 11:00 a.m. local time an Israeli
drone strike hits a car traveling in the
Village of kabet Salem 10 keters inside
Lebanese
territory Hezbollah has confirmed a
senior field commander with the Elite
rwan Force was killed wasam alil was
from the village he's the highest
ranking Hezbollah Commander known to
have been killed since October 8th
Israeli sources say he was responsible
attacks by the armed group on a key
military installation in the Galilee
that was launched in response to the
assassination of Hamas leader salal Al
aori last week his death will be a blow
to Hezbollah the man was highly regarded
as a very capable fighter and Hezbollah
supporters have shared pictures across
social media of him with senior
commanders some show him with kasum
suani the leader of the Iranian alud
Force who was killed in a US drone
strike four years ago Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu said sent a
warning to Hezbollah and a message to
Israelis living close to
Lebanon we will do everything we can to
restore Security in the north and allow
your families because many of you are
locals to return home safely and in the
knowledge we are not to be trifled with
we will do whatever is
necessary he went on to say that he
would prefer not to carry out a large
scale bombing
campaign those comments coming as
International diplomacy is enforced
swing to stop an allout war and keep
tensions contained within the disputed
border area the German foreign minister
arrives in Beirut on Tuesday and also
this week a top Diplomat from the United
States Amos Hawkin also arrives now he
was in Israel last week the Israelis
gave him a proposal to push Hezbollah
deeper into Lebanese territory and past
the Lani River but that proposal was
already rejected uh by Hezbollah hisbah
don't want to negotiate anything while
the war in Gaza is continuing so what he
has to offer will be closely watched
what power the diplomats have and how
they choose to exercise it will be
crucial over the coming days Miss US
President Joe Biden is seriously worried
about Israel's messages to Hezbollah and
wants to avoid a fullscale escalation in
fighting but as we've seen in Gaza his
influence is limited and Hezbollah is
clear the war on Gaza must end
Imran Khan Al jazer iaki Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer